القدرات بايدي القوات الاوكرانيه حتى
تتمكن من استخدامها على ساحه المعركه
وندرك كيف نقوم بذلك في ابريل الماضي
عقدنا اجتماع مجموعه الاتصال لتنسيق
مساهمتنا من اجل اوكرانيا وهذه الاجتماعات
تواصل تجسيد الدعم الذي يتزعزع لاوكرانيا
عبر العالم
ان مجموعه الاتصال هذه هي شهاده على
وحدتنا وحده الغرب
والجهد وكذلك وحده القيم
لا يمكن لاحد منا ان يحقق ما تحقق بمفرده
ولكن مع لقد قدمنا ما يقرب من خمسين مليار
دولار من المساعدات لاوكرانيا منذ بدء غزو
روسيا في الرابع والعشرين من فبراير
الماضي وتنسيقنا يحدث فارق حقيقي في الوقت
الحقيقي ان الولايات المتحده والمانيا
وهولندا تعمل معا لتقديم انظمه للدفاع
الجوي لاوكرانيا وفرنسا وايطاليا تدعم
الان لتقديم نظام دفاع جوي
مجموعه من الدول بما فيها المانيا وبولندا
وكاندا والبرتغال واسبانيا والنرويج
والدنمارك وهولندا تعمل معا لتقديم
الدبابات لاوكرانيا
للمزيد من القوه القتاليه في علوات
المتحده وتشيكيه والهولندا تقدم عن اكثر
من 90 دبابه وهذا اضافه الى تقديم بولندا
مؤخر للدبابات 72
والمملكه المتحده قدمت دبابات
مع بلدان لتقديم المزيد من الذخائر
للمدافعين الاوكرانيين
نعمل معا لتدريب القوات الاوكرانيه عباره
عبر تدريب ثنائي ومتعدد الاطراف على غرار
المهمه الدعم العسكري الاوروبي كل هذه
المساعده تقدم بناء على وحداتنا ولكن يبقى
لنا الكثير القيام به علينا ان نكثف
تركيزنا ان اوكرانيا لديها مطالب مليحه
حتى ترتقي الى هذه اللحظه الحاسمه في هذه
الحرب والرئيس اكد على حاجتي اوكرانيا
للمزيد من المعدات في اجتماعنا الاخير في
قاعده رامشتاين
انا سعيدا ينضم الينا اليوم وزير دفاع
الاوكرانيا
شكرا على حضورك لهذا الاجتماع نرحب ايضا
بالنائب قائد الاركان الاوكراني في هذا
الاجتماع نحن سعداء بتواجدك هنا وعروضكم
سوف تسمح لنا
لتركيز على ما تحتاجه
اوكرانيا في ساحه المعركه هدفنا ليس فقط
تقديم المعدات وانما نقدم قدرات دائمه
وسنواصل اليوم الحديث عن تنسيق دعمنا حتى
تستطيع اوكرانيا تحصل على القدرات
القتاليه المهمه والتي يمكن ان تستمر سوف
نسمع ايضا من الجينا بشان مهمه التدريب
التي تنجز في اوروبا سنناقش ايضا
المبادرات الاساسيه التي تساهم في دعم
اوكرانيا على البعيد سنناقش ايضا المساعد
للمساعدات الامنيه التي نقدمها لاوكرانيا
على تعاون فريقكم في هذا الاطار التزمت
اوكرانيا بان المعدات التي نقدمها تسلم
للمدافع الاوكرانيين على الجبهات القتال
وهذا الاجتماع ياتي في وقت حاسم فالكريم
لانه يمكن ان ينتصر ولكن بعد عام نحن
متحدون اكثر من اي وقت مضى وهذا التصميم
سيساهم على محافظه اوكرانيا في
الشهور والاسابيع المقبله
عندما انظر الى هذه القاعه اليوم ادرك ان
وحداتنا سوف تزداد وندرك جميع ما هو على
المحك في حرب روسيا التي اختارتها الامر
لا يتعلق فقط بحق اوكرانيا في العيش في
كنف الحريه والامن ولكن الامر يتعلق
بالنوع الحروب التي سوف يرثها ابناؤنا لا
يمكن لن نعيش في عالم يمكن لمسب الدين ان
يغزوا الجيران ويتجاوز الحدود ويقصف
الشعوب
جئنا للعمل معا لصون القواعد وسياده الدول